hi
we're taking a day off work and we are
exploring
parts of berlin that we haven't really
explored before particularly where east
meets west so we're here on the obam
which connects old east berlin and old
west berlin and it's called the
overbound booka because there used to be
a action actual tree in the river
blocking the way it was a municipal
boundary cool should we go east or west
i say west all right
look at the tv tower over there wow
amazing yeah yeah cool let's take a
picture of it yeah fantastic
i'm gonna get the tv tower in the
distance
it's a really nice view it's a misty day
in berlin
so
this is our first stop in west berlin
and for our first stop we thought we'd
do something a little off the beaten
path and that is
this pioneering urban farm and garden
princessing and garden that's it okay
fabulous
it's like an oasis in the middle of
berlin
look at that beautiful kale
i love making kale salads and i have not
really found kale at all here in berlin
so this is a major find
nice
look at this fabulous looking pepper
this really adds to the charm of this
part of berlin i'd say
this is this is why people like
kreuzberg because it's cool and very
different
go for it all right
i love turkish food
i love street food
sit down restaurant food
it looks delish
yeah look
these cabbages they're bigger than my
head i'm not kidding look
it's some pretty impressive architecture
i agree i kind of like the colors
i like the balconies too and this would
seem to be pretty classic you know
soviet style monumental architecture
for us as new yorkers coming here
precisely 25 years after the fall of the
wall it's really interesting to see what
you know to see what things are like
here now you can see the differences but
you can also see a lot of come together
wow oh check this out karl marx
honda oh marks buchandlung cool old
school old school you ready yeah all
right
it's a cafe an old historic cafe but
it's also a museum a museum to the
history of this particular boulevard
this stalin alle which has become karl
marx alley
very interesting it's a great idea to
combine them
here's our
kuken
banker
what a great day a great way to end a
great day in koitzberg and
thanks so much for being with us